[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
DIRK PRIMBS: Two
days of learning,
two days conversation--
I can't believe it's over.
Can you?
It's like it just started.
And we aspire to create a
conference for all of you
that is more than just
a technology show.
We aspired it be European,
to be a place of learning,
and to be an inclusive place
where you can get inspired
and have conversations and
just love being a developer,
around a developer crowd.
So when you design
something like this,
there are a couple of things
that you try to get right.
And then, you wonder if
you really got it right.
So being a place of learning--
kind of easy, right?
You ask the audience-- in
that case, you developers--
hey, what would
you like to hear?
You invite experts
that give session.
You put on an agenda.
Find a place-- check.
And after the event,
we ask you how we did
and how we can improve.
Being an European conference--
also kind of easy--
so in this room, we are
actually more than European.
We are a global conference.
We have 71 nations sitting in
that room, and more than 2/3
of you come from
countries outside Poland.
So this is truly an
international European
conference, and that was
what I heard from you
all over the place, that
among good conversations,
you really like the exchange
with other perspectives,
other nations, people
from other countries.
The inclusive, inspiring part is
a tricky piece, because, well,
how do you test for that?
There are a million little
things you can do and try,
and it's not easy to test.
It's more-- some would say
it's more a soft thing.
But wait a minute.
We can ask, right?
So I can run a
little experiment.
Maybe you do it with me.
I am going to raise
my hand, and everybody
who feels like inspired,
learn something new,
and being part of an
inclusive conference,
just starts cheering.
How about that?
Let's try it.
[CHEERING]
That was like
medium-sized cheer.
[LAUGHTER]
And it was kind of expected.
So if you look
around, and you were
some in the cheering crowd, you
might have noticed some of you
didn't cheer.
Because actually, you
know, we Europeans
don't cheer that easily.
Just because some clown on stage
says, cheer, we don't cheer.
And that's a
well-known stereotype.
Actually, we as Europeans even
subscribe to that stereotype.
So non-European think
that Europeans are not
that easy in cheering,
and Europeans kind of do
it and believe it themselves.
And these kind of
stereotypes we know.
But there are a
million other things
that are unconsciously
baked into how we
behave, how we make decisions.
Now, we are engineers,
so it's like a decision
tree or a filter, if you will.
Our brains are
remarkably good at that,
because that helps us navigating
the world much faster than we
would without these
heuristics, if you will.
So these unconscious
stereotypes, these unconscious
biases, they influence
how you make products,
how you make decisions.
A conference is a
product, if you will.
Software is a product; hardware.
You build products
out of these elements.
And your stereotypes
influence your decisions.
Your conscious and
unconscious biases
influence your decisions.
By extension, sometimes they
influence what kind of product
you built.
We at Google, we build products
that have a global scale.
We want everyone to be
part of this technology
build that we are all
creating together.
How do we build processes?
How do we design software?
How do we design
systems that are--
without realizing,
without wanting it--
maybe biased, as well?
Our biases creep in.
And if you take the
example of this conference,
this was an important
question, when
we started building
up the project team
and started working towards
these two amazing days we just
had.
So we thought in
this last session
of this two-days
conference, we'd
talk a little bit about how
Google tries to build software
in a way that's more inclusive.
What are the processes?
What are the practices?
What are the things that
we try to do in order
to overcome that challenge?
So please welcome to
the stage engineering
lead, YouTube,
Sowmya Subramanian.
[APPLAUSE]
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
Thank you, Dirk.
I'm super excited to be here.
I still remember my first
technical conference
presentation,
almost 17 years ago
in Paris, where I, the speaker,
was pretty much the only
female engineer
in the whole room.
To see so many women
engineer at this conference
has been amazing.
We've come a really long way,
and let's give a big round
of applause to that.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
As Dirk mentioned, I am
an engineering director
at YouTube.
And I will be showing
a lot of YouTube videos
in my presentation.
So lets start off with a video
of a favorite clip of mine.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Me love rewind.
Um num num num.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- (RAPPING) Trust me, on
my I-N-D-E-P-E-N-D-E-N-T,
hustling, chasing dreams since
I was 14 with a four-track,
bussin.
That validation comes from
giving it back to the people
now.
Sing this song,
and it goes like--
- Ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding, gading da ding
ding ding.
- DJ, get away.
DJ, get away.
- And it goes like--
- Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
- Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
- What the fox say--
- You want to change the world?
You're a goat!
You can do that!
[MUSIC - MACKLEMORE & RYAN
LEWIS, "CAN'T HOLD US"]
- (SINGING) Can we go back?
This is the moment.
Tonight is the night.
We'll fight till it's over.
So we put our hands up like
the ceiling can't hold us,
like the ceiling can't hold us.
Can we go back?
This is the moment.
Tonight is the night.
We'll fight till it's over.
So we put our hands up like
the ceiling can't hold us.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
So this is a clip
from my all-time favorite
YouTube Rewind videos,
from 2015, because
it really captures
the essence of YouTube.
YouTube started out with
a very simple mission--
broadcast yourself.
And it has grown into a global
platform with global reach.
We have over 1 and 1/2 billion
users coming to YouTube
every month, and
over 80% of our views
come from outside
the United States.
We are an open and
democratic platform,
with over 400 hours
of videos being
uploaded every minute by
creators all around the world--
making YouTube the platform
with the most diverse content.
In the time that it took
me to say this sentence
or for us to debug
that problem earlier,
almost a full day's
worth of videos
have been uploaded to YouTube.
What makes YouTube
special is that,
unlike traditional
media or television,
we have no gatekeepers.
Anyone can have a voice and
reach and build an audience.
While this is still very,
very true about YouTube,
a few years ago,
when I was looking
at some usage data on
YouTube, I realized
that as our platform
and usage have grown,
human dynamics and
unconscious biases--
like what Dirk was
talking about--
are creeping in.
And on YouTube, too, we
see biases and gender gaps,
for instance, like
traditional media.
On YouTube, too, we see a
lot of our makeup videos,
for instance, are created
by female creators.
And a lot of the science and
engineering and technology
videos are made
by male creators.
With this insight, I started
a conversation and a pitch,
within YouTube and across
Google at-large, whose mission
is to build products
for all, about diversity
in the context of
product design.
And how does unconscious bias
play into product engineering?
What if, in YouTube, in
addition to optimizing
for the growth of watch time,
we became more intentional
about our demographic
goals, such as gender reach
or ethnicity reach?
That would unlock opportunities
for deeper engagement
and onboard more users,
thereby driving growth.
So for the first time in Google,
we expanded our dialogues
around diversity at Google, from
being about hiring and building
balanced teams, to about
diversity becoming a core piece
to defining the growth
strategies for all
our products.
And that brings me to today's
topic of inclusive design
as a growth accelerator.
So what is inclusive design?
It's about engineering
products for all your target
users across all demographics.
When you broaden your
demographic reach,
you're increasing
your user funnel
and thereby driving
growth for your products.
Inclusive design is not
just about user design
or visual design.
It is also about machine
learning and algorithms,
about the training
data, about testing,
about how you launch the
product, the branding,
marketing, and more.
Inclusive design is about asking
which target user segments
could you be doing more for?
It could be gender-based.
It could also be that
your products were great
when you have good connectivity,
but then doesn't work that
well in the developing world.
It could be about
optimizing your products
for certain ethnicity groups.
As an industry, we all have been
doing inclusive design for lots
of years now in the form
of accessibility work,
and this is about expanding
that across other dimensions.
For instance, when
airbags first came out,
there were more deaths and
injuries in women and kids.
Why?
Because airbags were
tested with only tall,
male crash test dummies.
Were the engineers who
designed this sexist?
No.
It's because of the
unconscious biases
that informed their process.
Female drivers tend to
have a smaller build
and in real crashes,
have 47% higher chance
of severe injuries than men.
So once the industry included
women in their design
and started using
female crash test
dummies, the safety of
airbags went up significantly
for women--
and not just for women, but for
anyone with a smaller build.
So this is an example of
gender-based inclusive design.
Airbags still don't
work well for kids,
and that is an
opportunity of growth.
For this next two example
that I want to show you,
I'll start with a video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- My coworker Juan and
I are sitting in front
of an HP media smart computer.
It's supposed to
follow me as I move.
I'm black.
I think my blackness is
interfering with the computer's
ability to follow me.
- So she moved this way,
and a camera followed her.
And then he'd get
into the screen,
and it would be
completely stable.
- No face recognition
any more, buddy.
My
[END PLAYBACK]
[LAUGHTER]
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: So, anyone
know what's going on there?
For this, we need to go back
to the 1950s, when Kodak
was dominating
color photography,
and they've introduced
the Shirley color
card, which has become the
standard for all photography.
But it works better
with lighter skin tones.
So what this means is you
often have exposure issues
when taking multiracial photos.
This problem was recognized as
a big problem in the 1970s, when
chocolate makers and
wood manufacturers
were having a hard time
creating advertising
material for their products,
because they could not
capture in photos the
different shades of brown--
so a funny way for this
problem to get surfaced.
It also was becoming
an increasing problem
when the media and
television world was starting
to become more diverse.
Finally, 25 years later, in
1995, a group of engineers
took an inclusive
design approach
to help bridge
this gap, and they
launched multiracial color
cards, which have significantly
improved camera and
photo technology
and helped unlock a lot
of advertising revenue
and new business opportunities.
While things have
improved, there's
still a slight light
skin bias, which
is what you saw in
the video earlier.
The black color skin
is not recognized
by the camera, which is why,
when the black person was
moving, it seemed so stable,
but the face recognition
was able to follow along with
the white-skinned person.
I'm really proud
that, at Google, we've
taken a proactive,
inclusive design approach
to helping bridge this gap.
And the Google camera team is
helping solve this problem.
Let's watch a video on what
the camera team has done.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Pictures tell stories.
It doesn't really
matter if it's a selfie
or if it's a portrait
that somebody
is taking of another person.
You are sharing in
that human moment.
- Let's take a
picture of you two--
one, two, three.
No, he's too dark.
- So this is where the
discussion started.
- Here, just use my phone.
It's got a better sensor.
- A better sensor?
What does that even mean?
- Color tuning is an
extremely complicated process.
When we look at images,
what we try to do
is figure out how
much of a difference
there is between, let's
say, a reference image
and the image that we actually
are trying to quantify.
We were running some
tests on a product,
and it was the proximity
sensor we were testing.
And we said, oh, it looks
like it does 60 centimeters.
Then we looked at each other,
and we go, we're both white.
The technology itself, as many
people will say, is not racist.
It's just that it
wasn't tested properly
to make sure that the designers
weren't unconsciously biased.
Hey, there's an entire
world out there,
and we want to make sure
this works for everybody.
I love the fact that we
get to influence cameras,
that we get to share
those experiences of life
and emotion.
To me, that is what
imaging is about.
It as a vehicle to
express humanity.
- I'll take a
Picture of you two--
one, two, three.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: All
right, for this next example,
how many of you know of Cheetos?
A few.
Cheese Puffs or
the cheesy snacks--
it's a very American
snack called Cheetos.
And when it first came
out, it was only available
in one flavor--
the cheesy flavor,
cheese flavor--
until a janitor who
worked for the company
started adding chili and lime
to his packets of Cheetos,
to make it more
flavorful for him.
He was Latino and
loved chili and lime.
His family and friends
also liked the taste,
so he decided to
pitch this new flavor
idea to the president of the
company, who actually listened
to this janitor and
decided to experiment
with this new flavor.
And that unlocked huge
opportunities and markets
for Cheetos.
I'm happy to say
the janitor is now
an executive at the company.
It's a true
rags-to-riches story,
and more importantly,
it's a story
that shows cultural,
inclusive design thinking.
This next example
is from YouTube.
A few years ago, we wanted to
increase engagement with kids
and families on YouTube.
So we brought kids
into our UX Lab
to see, how do they use
and interact with YouTube?
This is what we see, yeah?
Everyone uses YouTube here?
Yes, many.
This is what we see.
But the kids, when they
saw the same thing,
this is how they saw it.
[LAUGHTER]
They didn't care about anything
else on the screen other
than the video content
that was there.
That is when we realized, if we
wanted to increase engagement
with kids and families, we
had to reimagine YouTube
from the ground up
and build a new app.
And that's when YouTube
Kids App was born.
The YouTube Kids App
provides easy-to-use
interactivity and safe,
enriching, and engaging
content for kids and families.
And we've done this
by improving our user
design and visual design and
user interactions, and also,
by making a lot of
changes to our algorithms,
the backend systems, and our
content classification systems.
YouTube Kids now has over 11
million weekly active users,
and we see the engagement
with kids and family content
on the YouTube Kids
App to be significantly
more than on Main YouTube.
This is a great example of
age-based inclusive design
driving growth.
It also demonstrates
clearly that sometimes,
for you to meet the needs
of specific target user
demographics, you
might have to build
a specialized product for them.
How many of you have used
the YouTube Kids App?
Hardly any, OK-- because
we haven't launched
in all the markets yet.
So I'm going to play the first
launch video of YouTube Kids
App, for you to get an idea
of what I'm talking about.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- OK, so do you want
to tell a story?
- Uh, sure, yeah.
Oh my gosh, now everything
is popping into my brain.
OK.
- Once upon a time, there
was a boy named Alex,
- Three sisters,
- A bunny,
- Two trains.
He got caught in a bubble, and
then he was floating around.
He went to France.
- And then he sees Dracula and
a few ghosts, and Frankenstein.
- And then the robot came
and ate the whole town.
- And everyone went like crazy.
- And then they had
to destroy the robet.
That was the only thing.
So they put it on
the sun, like so.
- Because since the
sun is made of gas,
it couldn't eat
anything thing there.
- He got surprised,
and then he jumped back
and popped the bubble.
And he fell.
The end.
That's really weird.
[LAUGHS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: So how
many of you use emojis?
Yeah.
You're not alone.
90% of the world's online
population also uses emojis.
While there are many
emojis to choose from,
they're fairly stereotypical.
The boys are portrayed this
way, as doctors, and police,
and others, and the
girls are portrayed
as queens and princesses and
giving haircuts to people.
So it's fairly stereotypical.
To bridge that gap and to also
be inspiring for young girls,
Google has added a
whole new set of emojis
to represent women and
men in diverse roles
and in a mix of hair and skin
colors, to be more inclusive.
This is driving
industry-wide change,
with iOS, Facebook,
Twitter, and others
embracing this new set of
emojis in their products
and platforms.
This is a great case
of gender-based and
ethnicity-based
inclusive design.
[APPLAUSE]
This next example is
again from YouTube.
How many of you have
heard of women harassment
in online communities,
like the gaming community,
through hashtags and
online commenting tools?
Some of you, yeah.
Many of you might have
heard of Gamergate,
where women gamers were even
threatened for their lives,
using these online
commenting tools.
A few years ago, in YouTube,
we organized a Women
at YouTube Hackathon
around the theme
of bridging the gender gap,
to drive grassroots momentum
around inclusive design.
One of the salient
projects in this hackathon
focused on improving
YouTube comments
to help women combat harassment
and feel safer on YouTube.
As a result of this
hackathon project,
we've launched
several enhancements
to YouTube comments on
our moderation tools,
such as making it
easier for creators
to deal with inappropriate
comments, blacklist words,
and also limit
commenters who are making
those inappropriate comments.
This is a great example of
gender-based, inclusive design
thinking to further
deepen our engagement
with our female creators.
It also shows that, many
times, grassroots ideas
like hackathons can bring about
change in product direction
and strategy.
So now I've gone
through several examples
of different kinds
of inclusive design,
some from the
non-technology world
and many from the
technology world,
and many from
Google and YouTube.
And now I want to
talk about, how
do you do inclusive
design at scale,
and how can you
become more proactive
in incorporating
inclusive design,
rather than being reactive?
So this is the typical stages of
product development at Google.
They're not necessarily linear.
We do do it in an iterative way.
But at a high level, these
are the different stages
we go through during product
design and development.
In Google, we are
starting to become
more intentional about
setting demographic goals
at every stage of
product development.
So when we are defining target
users, instead of just saying
18 to 34 age group, we are
also picking a demographic goal
that we would like to meet.
So we're saying 18 to 34 age
group, with equal engagement
from male and female,
or 18 to 34 age group,
with this level of
ethnic reach that we
want to get on the platform.
Once we've set that
demographic goal,
we propagate it through
the rest of the stages
of product development.
So when we're doing
testing, for instance,
we are very careful in
picking our test user
groups, to ensure that
they are reflecting
and mirroring the demographic
goals that we want to meet,
whether it is with users
research and user testing,
or training data for
machine learning,
or market research, or more.
Over the last two
days, you've heard
that Google is a lot about
algorithms and machine
learning.
And you could ask, machines--
why are they biased?
They should all be neutral.
And that's not the case.
There are lots of
different kinds
of biases that can come into
your machine learning systems,
too.
And I want to roll a
video now to show you
what those different
biases are, and how
we are tackling it at Google.
Let's roll the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Let's play a game.
Close your eyes
and picture a shoe.
OK, did anyone picture this?
This?
How about this?
We may not even know
why, but each of us
is biased toward one
shoe over the others.
Now imagine that you're
trying to teach a computer
to recognize a shoe.
You may end up exposing
it to your own bias.
That's how bias happens
in machine learning.
But first, what is
machine learning?
Well, it's used in a lot
of technology we use today.
Machine learning helps us
get from place to place,
gives us suggestions,
translates stuff, even
understands what you say to it.
How does it work?
With traditional programming,
people hand code the solution
to a problem step by step.
With machine learning,
computers learn the solution
by finding patterns in data.
So it's easy to think there's
no human bias in that.
But just because
something is based on data
doesn't automatically
make it neutral.
Even with good intentions,
it's impossible to separate
ourselves from our
own human biases.
So our human biases become
part of the technology we
create in many different ways.
There is interaction bias,
like this recent game,
where people were asked to
draw shoes for the computer.
Most people drew ones like this.
So as more people
interacted with the game,
the computer didn't
even recognize these.
Latent bias-- for example, if
you were training a computer
on what a physicist looks
like, and you're using pictures
of past physicists,
your algorithm
will end up with a latent
bias, skewing towards men.
And selection bias-- say
you're training a model
to recognize faces.
Whether you grab images from
the internet or your own photo
library, are you
making sure to select
photos that represent everyone?
Since some of our most advanced
products use machine learning,
we've been working to
prevent that technology
from perpetuating
negative human bias--
from tackling offensive
or clearly misleading
information from appearing
at the top of your search
results page, to adding a
feedback tool in the search bar
so people can flag
hateful or inappropriate
autocomplete suggestions.
It's a complex issue, and
there is no magic bullet.
But it starts with all
of us being aware of it
so we can all be part
of the conversation.
Because technology
should work for everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
So once you've
designed the product,
and you're ready to launch,
it's really important
that your marketing
branding and support systems
all are making sure to echo
the demographic goals that you
set out with.
Now, for inclusive
design to be a success,
in addition to everything
that we talked about just now,
it's really important to still
have diverse perspectives
and diverse teams and to
increase the representation
of diversity in technology.
So to this end, Google is
investing, through our computer
science education
and media efforts,
to increase the access
of technology education
around the world
to a diverse group
and to help increase awareness
of unconscious biases,
and also partnering with
Hollywood and other media
producers to change how
scientists and engineers
and computer scientists are
portrayed in the big screen--
because that can be
a huge influencer;
so another video, the last
one in this presentation,
showing what we're doing
with the media work.
Let's roll the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- When I think of the lack
of diversity in Hollywood
and the lack of
inclusion, I figure,
if I'm not part of the solution,
then I'm part of the problem.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- When I meet students
who look like me,
I see their eyes
light up when they
learn that I'm an engineer.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The most rewarding
aspect of this work
is showing girls
that they don't have
to choose between computer
science and their passions.
Computer science is really
just a tool for what they love.
- Computer code can do anything.
This one searches for signs
of life in outer space.
- Growing up, I was so
good at math and science.
But I didn't feel like
I could pursue a career
in [INAUDIBLE],, because I didn't
see anyone who would like me
doing it, especially not on TV.
- A Google-funded Geena Davis
inclusion quotient shows that,
even when women
are leads in film,
they still receive three times
less screen and speaker time
than their male counterparts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The only way to find a
source address is to access
and analyze the data [INAUDIBLE]
packets in this broadcast.
- We want technology
to look fun,
accessible, and common as
something to do for girls--
or, as some would say,
normal, because it is.
- I'm here because I wanted
the billions of women and girls
all over the world to know
that you can be literally
anything you want to be.
- Our CSM Media team
strives to change
the narrative of computer
science for people of color,
the LGBTQIA plus community,
people with disabilities,
all aspiring youth, so
they can finally see
their reflections in the media.
- As a woman of
color and a mom, I
want my kids to know they can
pursue any career, regardless
of gender or race.
- Yes, absolutely, if the
platform doesn't exist,
we need to create it.
- Google is in a unique
position to work with partners,
to provide students with
access to technology,
and empower them to be creators.
- It is so cool to see their
minds fill with possibilities.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN: So
now it comes to you.
I hope I've shown you today
the value of inclusive design
and how you can drive growth
using inclusive design.
I hope also that I've shown
you the ways in which Google
is doing inclusive design,
and what are some of the steps
that we are taking by
becoming more intentional.
Now, you, when you leave this
room, go back to your offices,
can follow the same, similar
approach that Google is doing.
I would also like to leave
you with a cheat sheet.
All right, the first thing
is, in your current products,
it would be great if you can
identify demographic gaps
that you have and the
magnitude of these gaps
and, if you were to bridge
them, what kind of impact
they could be driving.
Once you have that, prioritize
which gap, the one gap,
that you want to fill.
Because we all are
resource constrained
and can't solve everything.
So pick one or two
gaps that drives
the biggest impact for you.
As you bridge those
gaps, make sure you
have metrics and logging and
data to measure progress.
And when you drive big
impact, celebrate your wins.
Also, it's really important
to foster an inclusive culture
in your organizations.
You can do hackathons around
inclusive design teams
to drive more
energy and momentum
across your entire team.
You can also do
unconscious bias trainings
to make more people aware
in your whole organization.
So with that, now I want
you to take a moment
and think about the
one thing you're
going to do differently
when you leave this room.
And if you want to be bold,
you can tweet it @googledevs.
And make sure to mark
it with the hashtag
GDDEurope and womentechmakers.
Anyone wants to shout
out an idea that they
may be doing differently?
It's OK.
Anyone?
All right, OK.
So with that--
[APPLAUSE]
OK, so with that, I'm going to
invite Dirk back to wrap up,
and I hope you
enjoyed the session.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DIRK PRIMBS: Thank you.
And I believe I need to do this.
There have been a few people
having quite an adrenaline rush
back there.
And Sowmya certainly
had the same, I think.
Even Europeans can give
them an extra cheer, right?
Come on.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
You know, that's like
presenter's nightmare,
so I was really
feeling with her.
The last step on our
two days' journey
for me is now to say
a very warm thank you.
It has been an
incredible two days.
And we have a few
parting wishes.
You heard Sowmya's wish.
I have an additional--
please, don't be a stranger.
There are several ways to
stay in touch with each other
and with us.
Continue the conversation
that you take with you
out of this conference.
The Women Techmakers, the GDGs--
you name it, there
are multiple ways.
And it's kind of
hard, if you have
walked these halls
these past days,
not to have bumped into them.
And maybe you're
a member already,
or maybe you're interested.
Stay in touch.
On your way out, there
are on the entrance,
I've been told, a
couple of things
you might consider grabbing.
Apparently there's
some schwag left.
So if you keep
your eyes open, it
might be interesting
what you see.
And with that,
please travel safely.
Thank you for being
with us today,
and yeah, maybe next time.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]